seven
eight
nine
ten
okay what is Eric doing and why I'm
getting swole bro what are you doing
let's go
oh my gosh
Control Alt is it Control Alt
on your promoted night checkmate
wow I'm thinking about doing something
for content
nah I'll just take a pawn move the
bishop back no no my Bishop ah it's a
mouse slip
everyone's not falling for it though oh
upon fell for it let's go it's a castle
fork okay this is a pretty routine win
no
[Music]
um
I don't know I don't know why you're
saying complicated
you play real good on YouTube
yeah
and follows my trick
wait for it wait for it wait for it
yes
stock fell for my trick where's my
castle mate
always play off six
always castle with Checkmate
this is actually far from simple
my game will also resign wait what but
it's a complicated position
no Simo gel Mia
as a newly gifted sub
oh my queen my mouth slip
oh no my knight
oh it worked
it worked
it's the same tactical pattern as like
the that one England Gambit trap
I still have to be careful here
but okay
life is pretty good
um as long as this bishop can't check
the king
oh
no my queen I didn't even have time to
say oh no my queen I wasn't expecting
Levy to fall for that I would understand
if Levy wants to rage quit right now how
do I see Levy's reaction lovey where's
my lovey uh
that's I don't know how the I don't know
how I'm sorry for the language
looks like he's handling it okay though
wait for it wait for it
do other people smell it too
[Music]
smelling it from a distance
it's actually really close
get ready for it
okay I'm using the keyboard shortcuts
don't you dare resign
let's go
oops
no
I really want to take on A3
please let me do it please play Queen S6
let's go is it I don't know if it works
though it looks so funny
oh no my queen
if takes like Pawn mate B2 Checkmate
green here doesn't help Rook takes G6
doesn't help
and I'm certainly made in one
I don't see a defense for white
wow that's why you never resign
oh wow
Chuck go this way
yes
Chuck
let's go
counseling to attack the rook and also
Checkmate to play this but uh it's a
spider ah
wait for it wait for it wait for it
wait for us
we have plenty of time
wait for it wait for it
yes
I never resign when you have a knight
okay time to resign
[Music]
Ed
I'm trading Queens
let's go
oh
checkmate
uh
it would be stalemate if I didn't have
my Pawns
hey it's still me
in trouble
let's go okay one one thing I'll teach
you you can play Bishop in this position
yeah
I'll play Knight but you can still
transpose back into the Stafford if you
play Bishop C5 yeah I know yeah I have
my own line that I play it's not all
about you Eric
Knight
this is a fun one too right yeah
I'll teach you something sorry Paul
everything else looks fine random
challenge what
I didn't see that coming I wonder if
it's a reverse green found
like G3 and then C5
Bishop G2
and then Knight F6 and then I didn't
have Knight C6 in my previous guess so
maybe Knight C6
here
here
castling Knight of six okay this
actually makes some sense I think I'll
try this I hope I'm not overlooking any
anything that doesn't match up but this
this is a line as far as I know
hey got it in two okay
this is what I need
let's go six move win
okay so this is four player chess
with uh oh dear
this is four player chess with no turns
okay there goes one king
there goes another king
he he
okay
oh it feels so good
I'll play E4 again
dessert again
hey it's a third orthostop in a row
opponent uh not allowing the orthostop
though
Knight D4 is the best move here
do I go for immediate mate
I'm gonna play D4 first after it takes
a little bit better
oh thank you Matthias welcome back
ooh free no not a free Pawn but let's
checkmate oh let's watch the Hikaru clip
this will be fun to watch
playing down two queens
I mean okay yeah
his opponent fell for it again I've seen
Eric do this like five times where
someone does this and they expect to
pre-move and there's no pre-move I knew
that was gonna I knew Eric was gonna
move the king and not take the queen
that is so bad
Queen ticks
I feel like I'm about to blunder
something takes if takes with Bishop
there's Knight C3 but I can take with
Queen
okay Queen D7
a very iffy position
maybe Queen no no no no no no no no no
no no no
I meant to draw the arrow not click
I was thinking Queen A5
how nice will my opponent be there's not
even take backs
also sorry I forgot to change the scene
I wonder if my appointment will like
play a waiting move and then allow me to
play Queen A5
I have chat disabled we can't talk I
can't even send emojis upon so flustered
though what's gonna happen I think
they're feeling bad for me
that's so sad I wanted to not lose a
queen upon's calculating the very deep
line
Bishop takes B5
it's so devastating
offer draw no I'm not gonna offer a draw
if my point offers a draw maybe I accept
I think I'll just be sad
Queen B5 was probably one of the only
moves I could play that makes my
opponent think for this long
I think they're waiting for me to resign
I don't know though
like there's so many Unwritten
messaging going on right now
they were probably just waiting for me
to resign I was waiting for them to be
nice to me
but they're not being nice to me
oh I'm so sad
okay
can defend
oh no my queen
oh no my queen Jade uh black didn't fall
for it
oh no my Rook ah
Black's not falling for anything oh no
my knight
my meeting
am I actually meeting here
I might be mating
checkmates
I haven't had this one in a while oh no
my queen da someone call an ambulance
but not for me